crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every to see you
already do though
Orion take the soccer star JUCO
above-ground cool goes better than most
Jade Lawson self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we go again
[ __ ] the crab feast
I
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
know the Tuesday the crappies but I am
touching pitches all the way up that
elevation I'm working on my circular
breathing man you know what circular
breathing is yeah people do didgeridoos
do it
trombonists that we call them to bits I
don't know about - what's it - it's a
trombone I'm a tube is flat - best is
probably a to best she's talking about
pre-emphasis
now I tell them what pre-emphasis how
you pre-emphasis uh I took sickle-cell
swimming in the ocean the other night
9:30 p.m.
a little 10 p.m. half-hour dip in the
cichlid almost wouldn't get in it was
cold he almost wouldn't get it I go you
get your ass in here and he's like I
can't do it it's so cold and I go over
and I start splashing you don't splash
me don't splash me I go sick list if you
don't get in this water I'm gonna tell
people a podcast you didn't get in wars
like I'm doing I'm doing it and then
he's love glad I did it was AF our list
we felt amazing list then I got bit by
some he did not get I got bit by
something he could I got never seen Jay
Larson hustle like that either
I got and I you thought I was kidding
though but my point was I will kept
running to the sand as we were out we
were out there pretty good ways I didn't
think when you initially tell me you got
bit I took off I just don't want to be
the guy that gets his leg eaten by a
shark yeah you just wanna leave my to be
the guy that's gotta run - man I want
what I think may have happened is maybe
a grunion banged off your shin or Runyon
that it was the back my back of my calf
yeah I'm a half or maybe some seaweed
rubber G care if there was a money you
did not go to Urgent Care
what's up everybody Larson here Jay
Larson commie calm Jay Larson comedy and
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Pinterest
I see all to repin and me I'm having a
baby on Thursday so wish me luck
gradually thank you wish us luck kate is
doing well hopefully this was gonna be
an easy baby only shows I want to
promote September 23rd I'm doing the
seat super secret show in LA great show
it's a great show and then together Ryan
and I are gonna tell a story together on
October 3rd at nerdmelt Theatre at Mount
comics so if you're in town that should
be fun we'll tell a story together we
don't know yet what it's going to be but
it'll be fun
sickled Ryan Sickler on Twitter and
Instagram Ryan Sickler official on
Facebook Ryan Sickler doctor for all
dates and info the crab feast calm for
any and all craft fees related
information
hey hey playa shirts you guys look
fantastic them to us from everywhere and
they look good on you out there
goddammit all orders include free
domestic shipping and a flat $10
international fee and as always thank
you for however you support the show
Amazon is a huge help the new premium
episode is up you guys are loving that
right now live from 2015 Bridgetown
common amazing with Dana Gould and Ian
Karmel if you're there you know how good
it was those guys were great and saw a
couple of you out there didn't even know
there were five of them up that's it's
simple all the episodes are available in
iTunes and as Direct m25 downloads for a
dollar ninety nine just go to the craft
feast com click the premium app link and
you'll see them all there love seeing
the love on the Facebook fan page page
make sure you follow all things comedy
on social media and we're happy to have
next issue back this week look here's
the deal everyone's time is precious and
we want to give you the best of what's
out there and who has time to sift
through all the nonsense on the internet
there's a lot of nonsense out there so
for those of you who want premium
content and don't have time to waste
finding it there's next issue next issue
is the mobile app that lets you tap
directly into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using your
phone or tablet Jay Larson
you know what's interesting is you -
that's what I know and we're not even
saying magazines are time consumers
saying Internet because everyone's not
even you're not even using magazines
anymore why not have an app that has all
these magazines or name it you want time
gonna pull vogue Esquire Time Sports
Illustrated anything you want yeah
anything if you read magazines listen to
me I don't say this up if this is one
sponsor that if there's if you read
magazines
you should have next issue it just it's
a no-brainer if you
a tablet or an iPhone it just it's a
you're gonna save money and it's easier
you can if you're like dieting you can
highlight recipes you can highlight
things and start like your own category
it's almost like it's a Pinterest board
or something within within the app it's
the next issue app it's pretty dope man
and they let you go deeper into the
story with interactive content for for a
richer reading experience so sign up for
next issue right now you get immediate
access to all the top magazines
including back issues and exclusive
videos and photos you're not getting
that in regular magazines
there's no you're not gonna turn page
magazine in of videos in a public you
know you're sitting in a waiting room
and you're like damn I can't tell how
many times happens me I go to the doctor
I'm like I just want a Sports
Illustrated something but it's always
some [ __ ] I don't want to read that's
right usually 10 months old yeah and I
can go right on my phone or tablet BAM
read it right there the best part is
next issue is offering a free trial
right now a free trial a free when you
go to next issue calm slash crab feast
again you can try next issue for free
right now when you go to next issue comm
slash crab go sign up check it out and
if you don't like it then don't go keep
going but I'm gonna guarantee you if you
read magazines you're gonna appreciate
it and it's an app you can share up to
like I think five device five devices
nope I mean stop guys listen mate yeah
go to go do your thing
guys we're excited to have you here with
us and this is a guy Ryan I've both
known for a long time super funny guy in
like tons of different mediums stand-up
sketch makes videos and we're excited to
have them on this podcast with us please
welcome first time to the craft fees mr.
Garreth Reynolds welcome to the craft
thank you for having me thank you for
being I wish you were more excited thank
you you probably just got the longest
ovation we've given anybody I'm getting
a lot of mixed signals up top I don't
know what's happening
you know I'll tell you when I turn it
off okay when there are people that I
feel like I can jab with I love to jab
and you you you just have that you roll
you just roll with it have at me well
thank you so much for being here this is
certainly a pleasant surprise
thank you since I asked you to come
won't you let everybody know where they
can find you on social media and plug
yourself away you can find me at
Reynolds Gareth on Twitter and Instagram
was there a Gareth Reynolds yeah as some
guy already took it
what's his deal he's Welsh well he's
well he's a Welsh guy he took it and
he's super cool about forwarding
people's tweets to me oh he will but
he's still hanging on to the handle
happily so that's fun and then on
Facebook backslash Reynolds Gareth you
can listen to me on the dollop podcast
which is on all things comedy and then a
point versus point another podcast I do
with Evan oh nice yeah and what network
is that on that's on no network a no
network those guys are really taking off
they're good what I like about the very
hands-on competition they let you do it
they really let you explore and find it
that's good man thank you well one of
the things we like about you already is
that you came fully prepared you gave us
quite a little list of stories we want
to talk about and I wanna Jay's got one
to touch his home for him so I don't
it's a revenge story that's all I care
about it yeah a revenge by the I don't
like I like confrontation I like revenge
this is I mean this isn't really revenge
but the other day I was leaving therapy
of all places and where you should be in
revenge mode right you should be in
revenge yeah this isn't really this is
just more conflict I think than revenge
and I'm leaving I'm driving away and
there's this woman drive in front of me
and she's just putting along and I'm
looking at the land like I'm not gonna
make that light I know I'm not gonna
make that light cuz she's not moving so
as soon as I have an opportunity I try
and get around her light turns yellow
I miss it and it's gonna be a long light
and I don't know why I just left therapy
I should be in a better mood so I'm like
hang on I'll bang a right and then I'll
you turn down here and I'll carry that
green right uh-huh
so I bang the right and I go to bang my
u-turn but I didn't know some dude was
probably just as frustrated with her as
I was and he was behind me so when I
bang the right he's
they're at my left you know what I mean
looking at me and I look it over like oh
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
and the guy just goes the [ __ ] man and
throws me the bird and I and I just go
nope
not [ __ ] today no I just get he's
getting ready to get 9-1-1 on the phone
I'm whole you turn from there I start
following them explore in the explore
scary this guy's listen to me this guy's
flying and I'm flying he's like trying
to blow stop signs I'm doing everybody
in a lot of trouble like a core some
peer phrase like yeah I was just so mad
because I was I was saying I'm like hey
I'm sorry I said like three times and
yet he gives me the bird yeah for real
finally we get to like a stop sign in
this three cars deep so he can't go
anywhere you know and when he gets you
get up on two wheels get along so he it
gets the point where he's gonna be the
guy okay but he pulls to the right so I
can pull up next to him oh and I roll
down my window and as I go hey man I'm
just trying to say any I look over and
he's going I'm so sorry man I just
overreacted he goes I saw you say sorry
but my gut I answer I was gonna t-bone
you I was so afraid to hit you and I'm
like dude that's what I was just chasing
you to say I'm sorry too I was just
trying to say I'm sorry and I chased you
to say is scarier than chasing it
extinct or the best part is he's I have
to go the other direction you know I
mean he has to go straight so then I'm
like we're both saying there he goes he
goes now go ahead man I go no no you go
man he goes no go ahead we're both
trying I know and I go I'm not gonna go
that way
kostik and then he left and I turned
around I went cause it's amazing
probably waiting for you to kill him
sorry you know
that apology mug he just goes into his
shell he's like I'm so sorry man anyway
I lo congratulations it was a great mom
so what did you in the therapist talk
about today every that it's a process
you know parent and it's wrong ain't
gotta go through it I'm ignoring mine
but I get it
she keeps calling no I mean my problems
but yeah where the hell are you uh yeah
so I got revenge in a Home Depot parking
lot because well that place is just the
Home Depot parking lot is the word like
is at times can be the most frustrating
parking lot in the world because the
carts are so [ __ ] big you got to know
everybody parks like an [ __ ] you like
many cars are all out deep and walk so
work back bottom mulch
that's right you want the most spots
right yeah right yeah the mulch so we I
just shot something and I had to return
this huge umbrella so that was really
what I had I had to go to the return
line which I knew was gonna be a [ __ ]
nightmare
and at the time I was dressing up like
superheroes for kids birthday parties
which was a really weird job and a job
where I wouldn't be able to use people's
bathroom for a company or just go
entrepreneur on it yeah all part of my
brainchild know there was a company that
hired me to dress up like spider-man or
Batman or Winnie the Pooh or you know
whatever the little shits wanted and I
so I got into a habit of pissing in
bottles in my car Ryan Sickler Method
Man yeah Larsen thinks that is like
barbaric yeah most people are freaked
out by it for sure
I think it's barbaric when you're in a
limousine going to opening down some
other guys dime and you want to take a
leak in the Gatorade bottle that's I
think a little I was turning my back I
was a complete stranger did you do it no
maybe we were in
and bumper-to-bumper 134 min long story
short we started drinking it like 9 a.m.
because I feel like it was like a 1
o'clock start were problems their name
or in a limo we're sitting still on the
10 I have to piss
violently I has the world's smallest
letter back then I didn't but and I
don't I didn't see it even an issue with
it I want to turn my back I'm gonna I'm
really gonna I'm I'm in pain right I
have to go he kicked me out in front of
I would have pissed on myself if he
didn't kick me out cars over here at the
overpass I'm Taha on the freeway here
another one over here like like a
grapevine area yeah I'm in the middle of
everything I run over IP and then
[ __ ] traffic starts moving I got a
sprint back to the goddamn I love that
yeah of course you're a limo with a guy
you just met who paid for your tickets
in his limo I'm about to urinate on
myself well what if the limo [ __ ]
stopped short you're pissing all over
about your penis no problem you want to
take a leak in your car in the [ __ ]
live mouth that's fine
all right here in the back of a limo
it's on opening day I keep a Gatorade
bottle in my car for that perp so that's
what I was like I would have like you
know it'd have a couple bottles on
standby that were like but you were able
to do it in the costume right is that
what you're saying well some notes I
mean sometimes I would have to write
before but more like on a Saturday or
Sunday do like five or six kids parties
damn so you got to be like driving all
around spun around yes you know your
traffic so I'm pissing in a bottle in
the Home Depot parking lot I mean I
guess my reasoning isn't that standing
outside the car no no in the car like
sit like sitting down I'm like with one
of my designer bottles you know sort of
peeing in the bottle and I'm near the
mulch so I feel like I've got a little
private area and then a dude pulls up
right next to me
and opens his car door and like hits the
side view mirror real hard and I'm like
mid pissed like it's like I did not
think this was gonna happen you know so
I like take something to like cover up
my dick in the bottle cuz you can't you
know as you know Ryan you can't just
like stop it you know you're liable to
piss on the steering wheel every angle
exactly why you don't do it in front of
a group of people on your own terms
go forth okay so you can't find out the
CARFAX by the way hey here's another
move just a little tip climb in the
backseat face out the back window on
your knees it's a lot easier face up the
back yeah like you're looking out the
back window different vibe climbing the
back seeking a bottle that guy's pastor
baby what's having sex with a 16 I think
he's marking a wide move is this and I'm
always worried about getting arrested is
I opened my front passenger door and my
rear passenger door and I stand in
between those two so that blocks most
everything okay I'm still waiting to get
[ __ ] busted from behind every time I
do it yes he well it's a dicey situation
like in that and that's I mean really
like the reaction I had to when this guy
pulled up was not like I wasn't like
cool and smooth I wasn't like excuse me
sir you know I was like and I was like
get the jacket over there and like
probably pissed on my jacket a little
but he banged into the side view so as
he's like looking he doesn't think
there's anyone in there he certainly
doesn't think there's anyone in there
pissing into a bomb sure but he like
looks at me and he like and I sort of
like put my hands up like bro you just I
mean we both know it's just him and he
just gives me the hands back like the
whatever hands mm-hmm and I was like
this [ __ ]
so I you know no this is just my
recreation no I'm definitely Peter
Parker at this point I'm not spider-man
Peter's paying and so then I go inside
and I returned this umbrella and there's
this woman in front of me like who's
like returning bolts like bolt by balls
it's like a crazy person so they're like
that's nine cents you know it's just
like what about this one like great
sense you didn't get that here she's
like a coins that's rusty that's a
finger and that's a suicide letter so
and then so I get outside and I'm like
oh my god this dude's car is still there
and not only did I have the one bottle
of piss that I just freshly made but I
also had like an old stale bottle that
had been in the backseat like a buttery
your old toil you know I mean ya know
thank you
then I had a [ __ ] I don't compare the
two you cannot compare the two
right now you're telling me that if
someone had to piss in a bottle of liver
or [ __ ] the Dorito bag some massive
maybe a frito can smell alone the smell
alone is going to be head through the
divider in the limo and piss now talking
about like Dino in the Flintstones he's
the equivalent for crazy so so the
dude's car's still there and uh and I
see the dude like far away oh he's
leaving leaving and I've beaten him and
I'm livid I've been thinking about it
the whole time I'm in there like the
nerve of this man and of people of this
nature and the only thing I have is two
big bottles full of piss that's a lot
that which is a lot and so I am start
shaking and I'm like [ __ ] it I'm gonna
[ __ ] do it
and I go to my car and I open both
bottles and I just real quick start
pouring them all over his car and then
splashing it under his door hand
the guy's going to Disneyland oh my god
he's watching this no he but he am in
those getting closer it's definitely a
crazy decision are you like are you just
[ __ ] like adrenaline pumping like
freaking out one time I had to serve
someone a subpoena like so I had to do
that you you know you got served or
whatever thing why are you doing that
for a job you say you got served hit him
in the face and the ball so then the
dude is just walking back to his car and
where are you now I'm leaving I'm
leaving now I'm going 900 miles an hour
getting out of there and as I want as I
Drive by he looks at me and he gives me
the finger
yeah oh my god because he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] just no no it was the
greatest cuz in my head I was like am i
a psychopath which I was but then he
like gave me the finger which I was like
ah yeah this guy's look like a war
that's [ __ ] awful ah they're just
covered as a popcorn butter pea that's a
good one ah now I'm gonna go back to
you're [ __ ] in a Dorito bag thing I
had a friend that we went and did the
Rose Bowl out in Pasadena and there this
idiot at the flea market
yeah flea market and we're out there you
know you're there like 4:30 in the
morning so it likes weight-wise selling
[ __ ] selling market okay that one man
for 30 you got to get there and set up
your basement Jesus okay so we're in a
like a u-haul truck we rented and he
needs to [ __ ] so bad he shits in a
McDonald's bag in the back and I'm like
you're a [ __ ] pig
and then the idiot throws it their
porta-potties oh no not that he could
get to they had to go like here's the
[ __ ] up why is he McDonald's more
that's the reason here's the [ __ ] of it
that's as close as this wall has thus
right now that was the chain-link fence
with the razor wire and the toilets but
even had to go like all the way around
to go first of all though he shits at a
bag well what's he peeing he I don't
know what the hell you peed it I guess
he peed in a cup because usually those
hand-in-hand I can't control I mean
that's some stuff that's a major could
might have had a rubber band it [ __ ]
dumps it there's a dumpster right next
to our spot he throws in the dumpster
and I look at em I go it's gonna be a
hundred and ten trees today we're not
[ __ ] standing next to your sh bag of
[ __ ] all [ __ ] day get in there and
[ __ ] get it and take it to that
dumpster out there he had to climb in
that dirty ass dumpster I passed like
five foot have to tell on that I've
never had to do that thing I mean thank
goodness let's do one day man you you're
so mad at one day you're gonna have to
piss in a bottle I would have no problem
in the bottle but I'm one day you're
gonna have any public transportation you
might be in a limo I am do you know how
good I am at holding my urine how good
man I'm one of the best I don't even
know what that means but my wife always
shows like you're like a camel you can't
cuz I'll say something like sickle-cell
man we'll be there how many times you go
the bathroom so far I ever since I've
stopped drinking soda and just started
drinking water I should probably talk to
my doctor because I'm flooding myself of
water I can't go like an hour and 15
minutes without having to take a leak I
can't do it I'm kind of like drank with
soda for hours so maybe I'm backed up I
don't know but yeah it's annoying well
but that's also the thing like if you're
on like a flight and you're like the
window seat and you're like alright yeah
I don't have to piss I can hold it and
then you just start thinking about like
well I mean I could piss I know like man
I have to piss and then you go and talk
yourself into it like just like a psycho
you could if you see a lot of psycho and
you they I love it um I said we know all
the time no people I want to come back
to the serving someone so you tell us
about that you serve for a while you
serve papers no I just had to do it one
time how did how did it come about well
my brother had moved to Glendale and
there was some shady like landlord dude
who wouldn't wouldn't return their
security deposit so I had to like come
up with like I was like so this guy
wouldn't return their calls they sent a
sheriff all this [ __ ] nobody would do
anything
so I have an out-of-state number so I
just called them and I set up I for like
a month I like set up the groundwork of
like you know what I was looking for and
[ __ ] like that and then finally there
was a day when I had to and when I was
gonna go meet him and look at a place
and I had to go serve in the [ __ ]
paper
you shaking like crazy because so much
history like we had like a relationship
like I felt like I was Donnie Brasco I
was like I've lied to this guy the whole
time and he had the door open and he was
so like oh come here come here come in
like to take a look and I was just like
said his name and he's like yeah and I
was like you've been served
and then I ran then everywhere I am he
had a limp too and I ran I'm not kidding
I ran like a block I was so like afraid
that he'd kill me
damn I love that that's yeah it was
stressful as [ __ ] though but then I was
like a champion yeah of course you and
then when I told this story I told her
look I was much like away yeah way cool
I was like I looked at the place the
best thing about you is you're kind of
like the and I don't mean this
so listen to hear me don't weightless
what I'm about to say you don't just
hear me all the way out okay you know
like in like the movies the geek in high
school who's so afraid to do something
that he does it you like that cuz the
[ __ ]
I love how nervous you get to do [ __ ]
you like [ __ ] it I have because so many
people get nervous just like they don't
fall through
I mean pouring urine on someone's car's
nuts but I think it's awesome that
you're like [ __ ] that man I'm doing this
[ __ ] and even though it scares you to
death yeah that's the best it's like
Heights in real life like David ever you
know ground Heights you're scared
Heights
terrified of heights how high is too
high
I mean not very like if I'm gonna play
and I'm fine but it's like if so I have
to I'd you know yeah we had a Travel
Show a couple years ago yeah and when I
had a bungee jump I had to go like on
zip lines and a rainforest in Alaska
I love the zip lines no big deal bunch
jump I don't know if I could do now this
is I just don't know well we were
supposed to skydive two with [ __ ]
Navy SEALs
I just perfect you might want to watch
out means are drafting here that comes
down I don't know what's that I don't
know Gareth ate a pound of salami listen
I'm not I'm like a bad dog I don't know
everybody yeah but so like anything that
I'm out of control of doesn't really
bother me but it's when I have to like
be in charge of myself away and my word
yeah or any of that [ __ ] like ziplining
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me you
weren't you didn't feel secure I mean we
were in these we were on trees and like
the trees are like moving a little bit
and like no I really didn't I really I'm
not at all yeah I mean there were times
where you had to like unhook it for a
second to like hook up to something else
yeah I mean I just couldn't wait I
couldn't [ __ ] handle it I get I don't
get scared of heights but I'll get I
don't know if it's vertigo sometimes but
I'll be in high Heights and I just
looked down I'm like just job alright
yeah no job no like it like the I know
my you better keep going to therapy you
know I mean ya know when you have that
crazy voice in your head it's like it's
not crazy I'm just saying like the idea
we we were just up in Seattle not long
ago for a family vacation and there's
this bridge there's an area called
deceptions pass and it looked deception
pass and it's the shadiest dude it's
this where it comes in and it ends up
being like a crazy whirlpool that will
pull the biggest ships around and I
don't think like nothing like that I'm
just saying enough to throw them off and
you know that where they can't get right
elves right sometimes and they have a
very narrow walk bridge like this it's
so [ __ ] high up and this sides that
like thick cable you know I mean but
that's like barely yeah that's Don is
walking with Stella in her arms and I
start walking behind her and I look over
and I was like oh no no no [ __ ] this and
how far was it a cross down across it's
a good one it's a good trek across like
what 40 there's two of them I'd say 50
60 the first one and then there's like a
little bit of roadway and then I think
it bends and there's another for like 20
30 something like that and you're
walking across and how far down is I got
10 steps onto the [ __ ] thing and I
look down
hundreds of feet Jesus yeah no way yes
and I was like he's not even in a damn
she's not even in a stroller anything
like what if she were to push up she's
like what are you talking but there
there was a that wasn't just a cable
there's a barrier but you can see
through the barriers you know I can see
through and I was like out now I'm gonna
just chill here with the baby and then
Edie who's our buddy that was driving he
was he came back to the RV and he's like
I can't let you hang here by yourself
I'm like I'm a hundred percent comfort
we got skin oh he's like no no we're
gonna drive over and meet them on the
other side so like I strap Stella in and
we're rolling over and that's when I
didn't realize so we got over the first
miles like yeah [ __ ] this that we come
around to climb like there's two like if
I wouldn't you couldn't see it from
walking like if I got across the first
one you're like oh did we turn across
right there I'm on man I would have been
pissed that [ __ ] was I wasn't down for
that I think I'm starting to get scared
of heights it's crazy the older we get
those little things that you're like I
mean right now I'm not even exaggerating
right now I'm pretty sure I have a blown
rotator cuff in my left shoulder a
sprained right wrist
I got an ACL out I swear to god dude the
thirty-day do look at the chart of
myself look at the little things
man you know how I banged up my knee I
tried to do a jackknife into the pool
the other day to make Reed laugh and I
was too close to the shallow end and
like my ankle hit the bottom I cheated
and I was like I came up and they're
like oh my God look at Reed & Reed's
laugh and everyone's laughing I'm like I
think I blew off my knee did you say it
or did you privately no I said I would
have hit it I'd have been like I'm great
I'll be inside just falling apart we're
just getting everything is heightened at
this age no I just broke a rib like two
weeks ago now riding on the back of my
friends moped drunk yeah mopeds so
things are good but I mean that was I
was like the next day people like wait
what you do and I was like well you hear
it you're gonna think it sounds crazy
but like we was just riding though or do
you follow just right no we were you
know he hit a curb he hit a car you or
both of you both well the thing just
tipped it wasn't like super hard but it
doesn't take much so and then down
your side right down to my side and then
and then I had like four days of denial
I was like it's muscle yeah that's got
to be muscle and then I went to the
doctor and I eventually got her to say
why do you keep comparing yourself to
NFL players she did oh yeah well in the
NFL she's like huh well they take a lot
of drugs
well Tony Romo last year she was like
what's happening who do you think you
are she's like what yeah they're crazy
what do you do
you're a writer okay yeah no don't do
anything did you get x-rays yeah yeah
okay yeah good for you thank you man
things are good things are finally
happening I'm breaking ribs yeah like
you know I throw piss on cars things are
coming together you told us you had such
a list before I don't know what I want
to see next how about the jury how about
the jury story so I so I got like I'd
this is when I didn't know that you
could just straight-up throw out jury
duty forms do you guys think you can do
that I've never got this photo oh really
yeah yeah I knew you could do it a long
time ago someone I don't know where I
read it or something I thought it was Al
Capone or one of those oh well that's
somebody who you want to follow but
listen that's not what I'm saying I
think it was one of those old gangsters
that said I refuse to be judged by a
jury of my peers that are too stupid to
get out of jury duty
yeah and that was it and it's when it
comes to in the mail it's a summons
which is legally a suggestion to come to
court so I would throw them away all the
[ __ ] time yeah and then I got a big
red [ __ ] notice that said your ass
better [ __ ] come into court they
speak him right that I came that's what
it said imprint I came I can't send him
to the bottom line Department and and
you know what I should have thrown that
away yeah I went into court a totally
and I asked a lady and I said that to
the lady I go well technically this is a
summons like you should you should
subpoena me if you if it's mandatory for
me to be here and she's like I could
give you that to pain
she's like yeah good service yeah and
she's like yeah that's that's some
[ __ ] in jury duty and I always [ __ ]
I'll tell mine after yours well okay on
a jury for a month so I'm for February
uh well it's a short month what's the
weird month I so I I will then what you
have to do is you caught a call every
night so you don't know when you're
gonna have to go in you have to call so
yeah you have to the night before all to
cheer like Monday through Thursday you
have to call like seven o'clock that
night and they'll be like [ __ ] sports
team yes all like a baby but you are
like god damn what's going the first
time I technically served I called so if
you call Monday through Friday and they
don't pick you on the call process that
can death equal serving yeah yes the
first time I served well and the thing
about the process is that there's at
least for me there were multiple times
where I was like I'm gonna be okay yeah
like I don't have to go tomorrow so of
course it was a Thursday they're like
come in so I go in and you again you
have to wait all [ __ ] day like they
call and random people so you don't know
you know you really have no clue when
when it's so at like four o'clock you're
like oh [ __ ] I might actually just get
out of here but at like four o'clock
they called me and a bunch of people in
and so we're all up there and then you
know you have to go through but you have
to try to not get put on a jury by
saying crazy [ __ ] and it's just like a
fun competition where like there's a
bunch of people in a jurors box you know
that and are trying to out-crazy each
other this one woman on my jury goes I
can't serve on this jury and the guy
goes wide she goes cuz I don't like the
way that man looked at me to like the
prosecuting guy was like what the [ __ ]
and so she got thrown out this other
dude was like I don't believe in law and
the judge was like what are you like
that's not a valid excuse but he got
thrown off and then the the trial was
gonna be about it was gonna be
translated from Japanese to English so
it's all Japanese people like all the
attorneys Japanese the defendants the
plaintiffs are all
japanese and ila that's in LA yeah it's
downtown sushi district yeah the sushi
district and keeping its [ __ ]
actually it was ironically over the
yellow pages there was like it was an ad
and motors about an ad in the yellow
pages they just called it the pages got
it okay how's it going good okay great
I'm just like I want to you wanna go I
just don't like a smaller case can be to
have a jury my I was a murder
mine was a also the guys were Mexican so
the whole time they're translating
Spanish and it's so hard to concentrate
that's what they were because their
translator you can hear everyone else is
silent you hear you know the lawyers
already on what he's saying she's a few
seconds behind it's so annoying and so
on and it's so long that there's two of
them
they'll take breaks yeah those two old
ladies I just go and yours was a month
so that's basically the situation that I
was going into yeah was that I got money
but in Japanese I feel like is more
fresh language it's a grudges so so I
end up like I'm like I come up with some
[ __ ] for I can't serve on the jury
like I'm like well because I'd been like
I did this dumb I like worked on this
dumb marketing thing so I was like it
was like about advertising in the yellow
pages so I was like oh I worked in
advertising for a year and I think that
you know people in advertising are
terrible and I'm like opposed to
advertising or whatever was I was like I
hate advertising I don't believe in it
like that guy was law but at me with
advertising and also I don't like the
way that guy looked at me either
oh and a third thing I poured to to
Gatorades a urine on a guy's [ __ ] couple
days ago just get that fly man this was
try that was in the same couple months
just adds up things are good with this
guy that is really what I should have
just said and then just start itching my
neck a lot so so then they move on they
don't throw me off the [ __ ] thing so
then time
that's the one team you don't want to
make yeah so then basically the time
expires and they're just like all right
this is the jury yeah and I was like no
oh now it's so I've taken the oath and
I'm like oh my [ __ ] god no cuz I it
was gonna be a month that it was gonna
be that and I was like [ __ ] and I was so
[ __ ] mad and I'm like dry I'm like
driving in the traffic from the
courthouse home and I'm like this is
gonna be my life like I'm just gonna go
here every day and listen to these
Japanese people fight in their beautiful
language that I can get lost in but but
that's just gonna be what it is for like
four dollars a day or whatever they're
like you know and you got like a
croissant or something it's gas money
one way yeah they don't pay you to drive
home they only pay in one way and
everybody's crazy like the jury is not
like everybody is like people I [ __ ]
got the same situation hold on a second
real quick did you get the dirt did you
do the case well so so then I go home
and I'm [ __ ] so pissed and I call a
buddy of mine and I'm telling him and
he's like well why don't you just go and
tomorrow and just tell him that you're
racist and I'm like no I was like
there's no you know then then I started
thinking about it and then I was like
well I mean it's not crazy to me that
they were all I've done creamy I've
thrown piss on cars I've done crazier
and so then the next morning I woke up
and I was like yeah I'm going with this
and so I called the courthouse
and and I talked and again I get to the
bailiff and I'm like hey man there's
something and the really is like an
actual legs I'm not decided since
yesterday yeah I was I was like there's
something that I have forgot to tell the
judge yesterday
that I'm a racist individual just
totally came to me laughs my dad fought
in the war and I'm just yeah but still
here yeah yeah allowed to be yeah so so
I the bailiffs like okay we'll write a
letter and he's like and come a half
hour early
and you know you got to be there
whatever like eight or something so I
get there like 7:00 7:30 and I'm just
waiting with my letter and he comes out
and and basically my letter was just
like that at your hand right or you type
type [ __ ] okay don't like Japanese blood
no I mean let's say 11:00 feels good so
then so then I hand the letter to the
bailiff he goes in and then other jurors
start to show up and they're sort of
like you know shooting the [ __ ] like
like what's up man
we're chumming and in my head I'm like
oh god I'm just stuff jumping ship and
and then the bailiff calls me in and and
everybody at that point is like that
motherf I he did something you know and
I go in and everybody's there like all I
just thought it would be the judge but
it's all the Asian people alright all
the Japanese people are there and I have
to get into the jurors box alone oh and
I'm just like well I'm like this has
really gone very far very fast yeah you
know and so the jRD written it and
turned it in so there's nobody knows I
mean I probably nodded to him - how are
you guys doing how you guys doing you
guys good good to see everybody I love
that you're not coming out to announce
it that you're coming out to reiterate
yeah oh yeah for sure and I already know
when I walk in that's the deal the vibe
isn't like so the judge and the one of
the dudes is like looking at me so
understanding and I'm like he's a
sweetheart that's really sweet and the
judge made him - he's undercover so the
judges like so I read your letter
Wow crazy letter to 20 japanese people
about how you don't like or trust them
for some reason was she bait she was
like she she was like I read your I read
your letter and she's like and we've all
heard your letter and she's well you
misspelled race right broke just wanna
let you know Japanese does I have to
peace okay when I look at him all I see
are peace
your honor I really so relying testimony
this is not okay to do this and so she's
like I guess she's like I guess what I
need to know is can you serve on this
jury and I'm you mean kind of look past
my racism injured your honor so so I
really was so I'm basically like I am
like I go I don't know you know and then
I look at them go oh yeah oh I'm all I'm
Costanza on his way to the Hamptons
right yeah I'm like way too deep no way
so so she's like I want to know could
you do you think you could serve on this
jury so something about the moment I
love the cheese like I gotta think I'm
serious yeah she does have to though
yeah we all we're all playing the game
I'm playing the game she's like do you
think he'd serve and I just feel like I
just feel like I could maybe start to
cry a little and so just because at the
moment was so overwhelming so I start to
well up and I'm just like I don't know
I'm like I wish I could but I don't
think I can I really I want to do it
what's right you know and like there and
like all like getting this translated
like sort of like I hate you guys again
hi how is everybody I just want to say
you guys are fantastic
are the worst the worst and then and
then he and then like that this is all
being typed how many peas does he five
Jesus Christ so then so then they then
they like basically cross-examined me
for a second one of the lawyers asked me
a [ __ ] question
yeah II asked you I mean kind of have
you been to Pearl Harbor has examined me
and then and then I just get struck off
the jury then they're like okay well you
seem significantly crazy and racist get
out of here and then I left and all the
people were standing there and were like
he's sort of like as I was out I was
like take care everybody have a good
month I'll see ya oh I just told
and then I've never I've never gotten
jury duty since so I think there's some
you the racism I think they might have
red flagged me I would have like at
least hit up one of those people money
hey man just let me know how this case
turns out the update I really thought
that guy in the red had a shot I just
let me know I've put 20 bucks on the
defense
I um I will make my long story short I
has same exact process made it's like
Thursday didn't get called they were
they were sending people home left and
right and so you have to go in every day
no no you're just like Wednesday they're
like coming tomorrow however it did
happen to me where it took so long it
took two days to pick the jury two or
three yeah two days took Thursday and
Friday to lock the jury because
they were just left and right letting
people go like I was just a victim of
numbers had I been called early I would
have been gone too I was and I'm a
victim of numbers mister secular sound
e60 people easily for me and I knew I
was like they're just gonna say yeah so
I get picked and I think I was nine I
think I was no juror number nine and
it's a [ __ ] crazy I was on it for an
entire month and it was to Mexican dudes
who it was like half a million dollars
in cash automatic weapons
pounds of cocaine all exchanged it like
all exchanged at a jack-in-the-box in a
minivan and then they followed that van
back and then that's when they found the
guns in the washer and dryer and cash
and cat and I'm the guns are dirty
everything was dirt right and so they
called us they so one of the ladies you
know you're not supposed to talk amongst
the jurors really but we've got to know
each other we're together Froome you're
not supposed to do that yeah but they
can't help we got together for a month
and they would be like oh yeah we'd all
go to lunch together call each other by
your numbers and you don't [ __ ] talk
about the case but you talk and one lady
was she was older and she was scared and
she goes you know I think our records
are public and that's all anybody had to
[ __ ] say we all were like say what now
like they can look up who we are so that
spread like wildfire among the jury and
I'm 12 of us among 12 of us and one and
the alternates one girl so that's right
don't forget about the alternates can't
sit at the same table for the whole
thing yeah um the one girl said to the
judge in front of everyone like is it
true that our records are public and
he's like what's that now
and she asked again she's like well we
were talking he's like you're not
supposed to be talking he's like who
told you that and then she's like urban
strats that lady out I'm under oath
sorry lady then sorry three they're
doing you new seven was crazy
got into the Jersey they're doing the
old-school mafia [ __ ] where are these
two guys they're showing their headshots
the whole thing was done on a video like
it was well do oh they were part of
transporting and selling and they had it
they had we had phone transcripts for
days everything of them what every joke
they made to eat like it was all wire
tightly it was so sloppy and so obvious
it was these guys were definitely
involved in with their charges okay but
they would stare at you and they'd look
lock your eyes and then they'd start
writing [ __ ] on paper and look up and we
all of a start no once that once that
are part of formation was public people
got a little jerky a bet was ba but you
guys you can't we had the coolest
[ __ ] judge just do is all black dude
he's he's the most Zen human being I've
ever seen in my life so okay so give you
example of racism there was a guy did
the same thing like I don't like
Mexicans and he said everything he said
was he would go yes he would just say
yes yes
okay ma'am he's had two bailiff take him
but he goes sent him back down because
he thought he was leaving Oh send it
back down in the jurors poll make sure
you don't get on anybody any any Latino
case so you could that could have been
out of it you could have been a racist
that got reassigned yeah so the girls
like I was talking about it with her and
him and points at me so now they send
all the jurors back in the [ __ ] box
okay
and then they call me out like you by
myself I have to sit and everybody
everyone the two dudes the their lawyers
the everyone the judge and like now some
guy was eating an apple in the back the
lady said here's the other thing that
was scary about it too and we complained
is like anyone can come in and watch the
court case anyone can come in you can
come in you can go watch I should have
shown up from my case just to check it
up you're both sure they burn
J's arrested you and I can go watch his
[ __ ] court case right while they were
sending in these [ __ ] that look
like they were gonna kill people we were
like we would be so nervous that we turn
our chairs like and give you a pen to
write [ __ ] we're like that's the [ __ ] we
write like this guy's gonna follow us
you know and there were a lot of women
that were scared to leave you know we'd
all walk down to guests like women rash
it was real [ __ ] drugs and guns and
[ __ ] like you guys were the real deal
so I'm sitting out there by myself like
just like you and he's like okay the
lady said she talked to you about it I
was like I mean she mentioned like maybe
our informations public we weren't like
having a conversation my he's like all
right well you know that's illegal I'm
like yeah again I didn't bring it up
like it was said to me and then they
cross-examine me like you still think
you can go on this case I'm like yeah
yeah yeah you probably would be good for
you right now to get me off this
[ __ ] because the evidence is
overwhelming so then we go back in and
it's clear that everyone is not to
[ __ ] talk to each other about the
case anymore so then the next day this
[ __ ] [ __ ] comes over to me comes
to me with a cell phone he's like look
at this [ __ ] oh no look at this right
here you can find our information I
could do get the [ __ ] we were in a
government building so it was loading
slowly and it wasn't even up on his
phone yet I could just get it the [ __ ]
away from me I don't after yesterday on
II want to see it then he goes and pulls
it your move I don't know if he said he
was racist but he went into the chambers
and went in there and said something I
knew I liked this guy and he got out and
he's like I'm out of here everybody
we're like what he's like I'm out he
goes oh by the way I just told them I
showed you my phone in the hallway I go
what and they call me back
now he's a little upset like hey we told
you I go hey listen to me right now
hi you got a yeah I did another day long
this guy came over to be pulled his
phone up because we're in court
the shit's - I said a bit load and I was
like get it away from me they're like
you're not supposed to be talking about
I was like I swear I wasn't talking
about it they're becoming a real problem
mr. sickly all I'm seeing is the two
Mexican guys looking at you and then
writing down right but they're right
walls never write down is chatty cat got
loose lips um is the guy [ __ ] [ __ ]
the other thing that would scare me when
you go to jury duty and you're on a case
like that on the wall you have to you
have to say your full-name your urge
your address used to have to give you
have to say your city where you live and
it can't be Los Angeles has to be very
specific like I live in Studio City or
wherever you are all this information
and that every time I would go through
like why do I have to say that to
everyone like can I just tell you that
you know so then I can't remember what
it was that I do remember the lawyer the
lady for the city against these guys she
ended up it was so weird at the very end
of all because the judge was awesome I
love this dude he's like I'll just have
you know that you probably don't know
but the attorney here she's a former
Olympian gold medal she's a swimmer and
going let's give it up for her anyway
from the 86 games let's watch that we're
gonna bring in a little pool have her
swim around for a little while and now
this is where it got a little hairy and
like nerve-racking for me because I was
like look I didn't look at that guy's
phone and I never did so I go back into
our jury room and they go what Hey
that was the first that was the second
time but the first time the sex oh wait
after that the judge brings us all out
or he says they come back and they say
you guys cannot be talking back in this
room it's illegal to do that you can
[ __ ] up the case all that [ __ ] you can
lock up the case women were talking
their asses off and I went out there and
I said they said as anyone else talking
about this case and I
said no and I walked back and I don't
know why I said I just wanted to get the
[ __ ] out of that you know it's the heat
is it's you in front of the entire
courtroom being drilled by the judge in
these two lawyers and I was like no no
one else is [ __ ] talking about just
me so I go back in the room and I said
listen they just asked me if anyone else
is back here talking about this and I
said no and everybody in this room
better say no he's gonna ask us I'm not
even supposed to come back here and tell
you he told me this guy I'm gonna ask
the jury everybody better say no well we
all come back to the box and I'm nervous
I'm I've never I don't try to bully them
I don't ever think I've been more
nervous in my life no we were all
together in this these ladies were legit
scared like I would walk with one of
them still hits me up older lady
all-time checks in on me like a grandma
I ask how you still talk about the case
so she so we go out again and I just
assume he's gonna say okay jury I asked
Ryan whatever number nine if anyone's
talking about this case and he said no
is anyone talking about this case I
thought it was gonna go like that you
know how it went okay I asked juror
number nine if anyone was talking about
the case Jorah one anyone talking about
the case no juror two I was like he went
through everyone I thought was gonna be
a collective one timer he I thought [ __ ]
myself a Betsy four to their word
everybody [ __ ] said no I've been
horrible if the ladies wouldn't shut up
I'm getting [ __ ] hit yes sure nine is
still talking about the case he told us
not to mention it very controlling
he ended up you I mean unanimous guilty
the evidence was ridiculously over what
they get I mean years
years it was a big deal man it was a day
out they had picked hell no man this is
only like four or five years ago they
had I mean photos of ak-47s and dryers
and [ __ ] like that's right they were
yeah
[ __ ] jury duty man I haven't haven't had
to be on since man oh that was enough
for me man I was [ __ ] scary
people like people's lives are terrible
when they have to do that like your life
is just start [ __ ] well you're not
getting paid right you paid like five
bucks a day that's what I'm saying yeah
you know I mean yeah the money's good to
your point the money's nice the money's
are good think about it you got on an oj
trial I mean that shit's no money for
the entire deal at least maybe maybe but
yeah you would always want that would
rather stuff like anything that was like
an oj trial that would be like more
excited this was like yeah you got it
I had an exciting one Oh Jay trial
cameras be everything I would have come
in with Buffalo Bills gear the next day
they'd be like one drawer diggit leg
coca-c war 49er jersey and he didn't
know that
Oh Jaya played for the 49ers but since
he did he got [ __ ] bumped I don't
think it was I don't think it was an OG
a 49 injure that would be ballsy to have
an OG come in and OJ so you met on your
juror box for a sec yeah get out of here
straight up yeah I'm out of here babe by
the way I told them I [ __ ] myself I was
like wow boom call me right in
and by the way one of those Mexicans
cousins came up to me I told him that
you gonna vote against them yeah you
know what I did to here's how I'd know I
ran my mouth too much because I was
trying to convince the judge that I
really understood and I said yes I said
I remember it and I understood it the
first time you brought me out here and
said that to me and he like no we
brought you out the first time like it
was nothing
Wow oh well you really are becoming a
problem huh no I know
oh all right there's such a list here
let's hear about let's hear about this
one okay
okay well this I don't really ever get
invited to weddings like everybody like
more or Eklund like really probably like
10 percent of weddings that my friends
are all going to like I'll see on
Facebook and be like out I think I
helped them move so so I I got invited
to a wedding and my friend from
Wisconsin and I were gonna share a hotel
room and drive to like somewhere in like
Northern California and we went there as
a bunch of people that I knew from high
school there really weren't they were
there weren't a lot of people there but
we all started drinking very early this
is what I was like I don't even know how
I I just really wasn't even partying
that much but this day for whatever
reason I was just [ __ ] slamming them
I just was like drinking gin and tonics
before anything started I think the
reason was the same reason you don't get
invited to weddings like this guy goes
all out of way yeah I really yeah and I
had his wedding yeah so so I'm like just
yeah doing the things that probably
don't get me invited to weddings I'm
just drinking like before the ceremony
like the ceremony starts we're having a
good time and really getting shit-faced
and there's one there's there's
literally like one girl there who's
single and so we're all sitting around
having dinner and like drinking wine and
all this
[ __ ] and my buddy hands me a vicodin and
my other friend is like oh I want one
and my friends like he's like I don't
have anymore
but he's like I have liquid vicodin in
the room and I'm like I didn't know that
was a thing yeah I didn't know he's a
thing either we've been drinking all day
so I'm like oh great so I give my buddy
the regular vicodin and then we go up to
the room and and I'm like how much is a
vicodin in this liquid form but you've
just introduced me to it's a good start
right yeah so so a lot there's like a
good amount in the bottle but I don't
even know how much to do I don't know I
asked him I just found out about it I'm
like how much and he's like that he's
like the rest of the bottle is probably
a vicodin problem so there we go he's a
doctor and so I'm drunk and I'm like
okay whatever so I just drink it and
then maybe after for a minute of Mike
was that a good idea but I was like
whatever it'll be fine so then we're
back down at the wedding and it's time
for dinner
it's not even dinnertime yet so it's
dinner time and it really starts the fun
like what the [ __ ] going on over here
and like everything's like slowing down
and I'm like holy [ __ ] like I'm you know
and I'm like I'm sweaty so I'm like I'm
there and I'm just really like in
slow-mo and like my buddy's like how's
that vicodin I'm like it's very every
and so then we're you know I'm hanging
in there where we're drinking and then
and then I end up going outside and
having a cigarette
and I mean I'm just I can barely [ __ ]
like walk like I'm drunk and I I drank a
bottle of vicodin cuz that's the thing
and and this girl's like do you want to
do some cocaine yeah and so I don't
right but I'm also like well this is
like the only girl here so I'm like yeah
for sure
so then so then we go up to a room with
like her and like a couple other people
and and I'm gone I mean I remember this
but I'm just like not a human at this
point like the bike I don't know what it
did but it like it just made me like I
was watching the world through like a
bubble and so I was just like so I take
down a lot of cocaine and I am just
[ __ ] and I really you've done cocaine
prior to this yeah but like after I
after this night like I would tell
people this and they would be like you
should have died like something like
speedball I feel like yeah we're in a
cool crazy downer right now not a good
combination
liquid downer liquid downer and then a
good amount of cocaine and an upper
cause things were good yeah these are
great they're not the equivalent of one
vicodin people don't invite me to
weddings can you believe this I can't
and then so I end our missing out on
this man I mean it's just a party so
then I end up I really don't remember a
lot but I do know that like the next day
when I went down to the lobby like
everybody was like how you doing today
like I was like I'd clearly been that
guy the lunatic and I was like I'm good
why be like you sure
and I'm like uh-huh like old people are
coming up to me like hey you okay you
seemed crazy last night but so it all
culminates when I'm sharing a room with
my buddy and I am just like in the I
wake up and I'm kind of just like in the
middle of having sex with this girl and
I won the one single the one okay and so
I'm just like there and I kind of just
snapped to in the middle of it and I'm
kind of like what the okay all right
good this worked out good and my buddy
comes in I guess I'm doing okay I like
this guy and then so my buddy walks in
and he just like gets into the bed and
then me and and then I don't really
remember this but then the next day he
said that that she was like are you
gonna be able to finish and he said that
I laughed really hard so then I wake up
like before we go like I wake up in the
bed and I've just never liked what I
threw up
was like you know the Slimer hi-c
you guys don't know Slimer hi-c you guys
don't know ecto cooler oh yeah
green neon green and like purple and
vile but just the growth layer bio lab
bio by life yeah yeah and I mean almost
yeah almost almost died and then the
next day really didn't understand it
took me like two weeks to be like why
the [ __ ] who who just I thought I was
great I started a conga line yeah I
probably was doing this this isn't like
a montage that I've lost but I was I
mean I feel like I was definitely a hit
alright can we just take try and get an
image in your head of what you think he
did look like just sit at the table
after you must have just look like mmm
sure you probably looked like I had a
mustache and that girl still [ __ ] you
which is crazy crazy that just cause
what kind of before at the wedding yeah
no really you get invited back you're
watching on Facebook but it is true like
I never I never like for weddings and
that is just sort of spread like yeah so
now I'm just always yeah it's not worth
it and I'm fine with it cuz I'll drink
vicodin and do cocaine
who drink vikon him drink vicodin how
about edibles you were you mentioned
edible Australia tomorrow night oh okay
yeah and the last time I went there Mike
was asking what my formula was on like
how do you like playing all things
comedy for my friends yeah shut up Mike
and has tagged my friend and so when I
was flying there the way there I just
stayed an edible drank wine would you
have bread honey cookie you would like
chuckle --it okay it's like I'm when
even eat it before you get to the
probably like right when Reno the last
minute right when you're like you got to
eat before TSA personally no you're not
outdoor so so that's what I did on the
way there it is [ __ ] great because I
slept like the whole flight and I woke
up and I felt yeah I was looking
juvenille effets I felt like Sigourney
Weaver when she wakes up a nail I was
like I feel good and the people like 16f
like are you how are you doing how are
you we stopped in Nepal for six hours
well actually I did have and this is
dumb but I did have a sleeping mask on
and I had it under my headphones and
when I woke up the sleeping mask was
gone like so somehow you did some I
threw it in a rage
I've done this thing a bunch on planes
where I'll like wake up violently like
I'll just like from a dream like snap in
like with a punch and then like there's
two people sitting next to like Jesus
the psycho like I'm sorry I just was
how's everyone doing bad what's the
movie yeah so they don't take care
really shocking could I borrow some he
might swipe in your head I want to get
one of these movies this I woke up one
time on a plane and I mean I was I had a
vivid dream that we were spiraling
straight down I was with it no and then
I realized immediately immediate like I
feel like coming out of my dream I just
was trying to rope it jump so violated
your bear I don't even look over there
no you gotta we're crashing for real
have a little worried about this keeps
falling asleep when he wakes up shouting
now so on the way back from Australia
some somebody gave me trying to [ __ ]
Australia I was we say strike lightning
twice yeah it was like we're in weird
science when they're like try to
recreate
a little wine better than edible that's
the right amount and when I checked into
the airport I was in Sydney and it was
like [ __ ] torrential rain and it
wasn't that bad but when I got to the
airport like as I was checking in the
woman was just like she was like whale
o'clock you've been partying all night
you know and I was like I haven't been
but I was like what's cool what can I
possibly look like so we get to the gate
and the flight is delayed like three
hours
oh no and I it just dawns on me like
holy [ __ ] like I never even [ __ ]
thought of that
never dawned on me that it wouldn't and
I was like just take off and it was
really strong like you know you I I
really just jumped in head first does
anyone have an end up [ __ ] your wife
[ __ ] me while black down I need to help
get out of it so so I'm in the airport
with with with Dave Anthony the guy that
I do the forecast with and I'm like
tripping and I'm like I can't [ __ ]
tell him you know like no I don't know I
don't even think it was a good [ __ ] I
just was like I was like now he can't
know like guys like it's too I just want
to keep it real private he would have
been fine but I was like no so then we
went to go eat and we're eating and he's
like dude your eyes are like been like
I'm gonna pretend like things are fine I
mean I and I smoked a good amount of
weed and I'm like freaking out I really
am like this is tough this is a tough
phase I'm going through right now I'm
not enjoying this very much fighting it
yeah just that's all I'm thinking about
and he goes your eyes are really red and
I literally go I'm like ah how's your
wife what I'm like have you talked to
Heather and he's like no what do you
think Melissa my friend Heather I have a
texting her and then so I'm like alright
well I gotta go to the bathroom you know
and then I kind of bolt and I'm like I'm
gonna find eyedrops
cuz I'm like my eyes are so [ __ ] up I
really I don't know what's have less to
hide from Dave do anything so then
system like running around their Sydney
Airport is [ __ ] huge and so like I'm
running around and I'm eventually just
like you know I'm not gonna find any and
then I find a place that has on their
expense of his [ __ ] I get him and I put
him in and I'm like okay and then I'm
like where the [ __ ] were we just eating
I'm like [ __ ] I'm like where the [ __ ]
was it and I had and the airport's huge
and then so I start walking around being
like I mean I'm really [ __ ] obviously
I'm like where the [ __ ] were we eating
and I'm in the middle of this huge area
is like leave that boy crying oh yeah no
definitely not hi no wait I look is eyes
looks good and and as I'm looking around
I'm like what if Dave sees me yeah I'm
like what if he sees me right now
looking around like a [ __ ] lunatic
I'm like the jig that doesn't need to be
a jig is up so then I eventually find
him and it's like Ben I mean who it's
like beetlejuice time when they like
walk out of the house and like the time
like I don't know how it felt like it'd
been five minutes there's probably a
half-hour and then we're getting ready
to check in and I lost my ticket
oh so we're like wait and it's madness
because it's like a three-hour delay and
know what flights are saying about big
planes make huge so I'm like saying and
I can find you're holding up a city it's
not good and I'm just tripping and I
find like a piece of the ticket like you
know how it can be you know you
perforated but I find the way more
useless half it's the one that's just
got like two things on it and I'm like
today of him like do you think this will
work
and he's like no he's like there's no
way and then so I had to go through a
whole thing talking to them to get like
my ticket reprinted and then finally got
while you're hi just so hi to your mom
yeah and I'm like I feel like every time
I mean it's really one of those
situations where you just miss whiteouts
on
oh wait this guy's eyes are fantastic I
yeah but then I just land then I did
sleep like the whole [ __ ] way back
good work
yeah but it was like it works because no
yeah by the time I got on I was like
emotionally I was like ah what I'd been
through that day I didn't even find out
how Dave's wife was after all that oh
man yeah so that was and that I think
taught me a valuable lesson about oh it
did yeah what was that
drink vicodin up more often yeah or
sneaked the edible through and take it
when the plane takes off but aren't you
nervous to do that I don't do that at
all I mean I don't eat edibles before I
look I am scared you smile you smoke
weed but you don't you just don't do it
I mean yes yes but not before I fly I
mean you know even if I smoke before I
fly I'm like a half hour to get to the
airport I'm there an hour and a half
early shit's over you know I mean like
I'm not I'm always worried to overdo it
on an edible and then if I'm on a plane
I and I freak out I'm gonna make them
land that [ __ ] they're gonna they're
gonna be like it's gonna be gonna land
we got we get strapped to the chair you
know you know how strong they are
sometimes if you let me ask you this if
you felt like that while you were on the
flight what did it would you have had a
problem I think I would have been okay I
think like the that is the highest that
I've that was like high school high like
that made me feel like I when I was in
high school and it but I felt like what
I knew was that it would be okay I just
needed just sits down and just chill out
as much as possible and keep asking Dave
how his wife was but if I was on the
plane I think I would have been like oh
and I would have been okay enough to be
like okay just chill the [ __ ] out mm-hmm
yeah but it I mean it is weird because I
do feel like it's so rare that I'm out
of like
like scared on pot when it happens it's
[ __ ] real I don't like to be too far
out of my comfort zone anyway that's why
I just smoke weed beer here and there
I don't [ __ ] anything else nothing now
never done acid or I'm not in the pills
I've never done cooked the extent of my
cocaine use is I dated a girl that used
to when she smoked she would smoke
Parliament's cigarettes and she liked a
little bit of coke now and then and she
would scoop it with the filter and then
do a little thing and there was a half
of a filter and I was like it's not I'm
gonna do anything I don't want to do it
anyway she said just do it and I did it
and it made me sniff twice and then that
was it I mean it wasn't even enough to
do anything yeah that's what I'm saying
did you drive I know yeah liquid you
ever drank red vicodin just cuz it guy
said it was fine who's a doctor he was
your friend he said he was a doctor and
then you went in slow-mo during dinner
at a wedding yeah this is a lot of but I
don't even do I don't I don't do a lot
of drugs I thought that sounds like you
do sounds like and we got hour and a
half stories of them well sincerely I'm
glad you don't do a lot of drugs thank
you guys let's practice but we're at
that time man thank you so much for
coming on does a lot of my face was
hurting like yeah this is the really we
want more time with your Twitter podcast
all that stuff at Reynolds Gareth on
Twitter and Instagram and the dollop
podcast on all things comedy and point
versus point a podcast you can find by
just entering it into iTunes awesome and
this was a ton of fun thank you as
always Jay Larson Tommy calm Jay Larson
comedy and all social media Ryan Sickler
calm Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram
Facebook we'll talk to you all next
Tuesday
what's up guys this is the live podcast
recording from Bridgetown Comedy
Festival 2014-15 starting did you just
say 14 no why 2015 I will do is that I
heard you say 14